do you think you've lost by being born
black in a white country no I don't look
at it that way
the greatest influence in jazz of all
time Louis Armstrong
Jazz almost stems from Louis Armstrong
wish that was there
what did I do anybody who has uttered a
sound on American radio
it's because of Louis Armstrong's
Innovations
he never would come out publicly but at
home he had his opinions
[Music]
I've heard recordings of Pops just
talking he understood there was a battle
in this country
I don't have no flag rather than a Black
Flag
[Music]
there's a rumor that you invented scat
singing they came to me just like that
to be black in those days the
Discrimination was unbelievable
be so
his own inner dignity was able to make
him Prevail
over all these awful conditions he
worked with what did I do
he was the first black movie performer
to have his name above the title
he was trying to use his music to reform
and lead the country closer to his
higher ideals Arkansas had decided to
make its own laws on the subject of
integration Louis said Ike and the
government could go to hell everybody
was astonished but privately he
expressed stuff like that all of his
life
all over the world is in my skin you
have the respect and the love of
millions
[Music]
ask for to be so black and blue yeah
[Music]